the great advantage of liberal science
of our knowledge making system is not
that it does not make mistakes it's that
it catches mistakes very very quickly hi
I'm Nicholas B with reason TV and today
we're talking with Jonathan Roush he is
reissuing his great book kindly
inquisitors which was published 20 years
ago Jonathan thanks for talking to us
Thank You Nick the subtitle of your book
is originally published in 1993 the new
attacks on free thought in your in the
intro you George well wrote an intro for
you and he says that your biggest
failing is that you assume others are as
tempered as you set the scene for us in
the early 1990s what was going on then
that was wearing you so much about what
you call liberal science or kind of open
inquiry in an open set in open discourse
in society the late 80s and early 90s
were the blossoming of what came to be
called an political correctness which
meant a few different things but it
meant that on University campuses
suddenly people were being routinely
punished for saying things that were
deemed harmful for minorities or
politically incorrect at the same time
you had the Rushdie affair which really
motivated this book in many ways when a
guy wrote a book that was critical of
Islam this is the Setai Salman Rushdie
Satanic Verses and a fatwa was issued by
Ayatollah Khomeini
on his head and there was no resolute
defense of him in the West and I said
you know what he did when he wrote that
book wasn't very nice so maybe he
shouldn't have done that and then you
had an ideological attack on the notion
of robust criticism which was that you
know if you say things with words that
hurt people they cause offence
especially to minorities that those are
words that wound verbal violence
harassment and that should not be
allowed so you had all these movements
converging to try to control speech you
say the book in the afterword which is
worth the price of
new edition of kindly inquisitors align
you said the book has to patron saint's
CS purse and Karl Popper - how do you
mean that what what you know what are
they the patron saint's out for you
these were two philosophers they both
ought to be iconic in the libertarian
world who had two core insights purses
insight is that we make knowledge
socially we find knowledge by consulting
each other through public criticism he's
the guy who realized that it's a public
crop process and criticism open public
inquiry is the key Karl Popper great
Austrian philosopher comes along and
says yes that's right and it's an
evolutionary process of trial and error
of a discovery process much like the
Hayekian process of discovery of prices
and markets so it's going to be
open-ended and trial and error and
decentralize it's a liberal system talk
a little bit about the difference
between say a government or governmental
agency restricting speech and maybe a
professional Association at various
points one of the threads is the idea
and in the original edition of the book
you talk about a student in Michigan who
was got in trouble for saying that
homosexuals could be treat you know they
were sick and they could be treated with
some type of therapy but later you also
say that you don't have a problem with
the American Psychiatric Association
telling physicians that that's stupid
and if you believe that we're not going
to we're not going to certify you what's
the difference there and where do you
draw a line between a government a
coercive form of speech repression and a
legitimate one to the maximal extent
possible you want to avoid centralized
politicized control over speech and
thought because that will be used by
powerful people to serve the interests
of a powerful that does not mean that
speech and thought are unregulated in a
regime what I call liberal science our
modern knowledge making system it's
extensively regulated but it's done
through this network of people talking
to each other and through their
professional societies and one of the
points kindly inquisitors makes is
you've got to allow the system enough
space to turn aside sometimes quite
brutally people who the system decides
don't have good
and and oftentimes the system will be in
error because we you know I mean you
mentioned Hayek before he's a guy in the
40s and 50s it was kind of on the edges
of the economics and social science
world and you know by the early 70s that
won a Nobel Prize so the great advantage
of of liberal science of our knowledge
making system is not that it does not
make mistakes it's that it catches
mistakes very very quickly talk a bit
about Frank Kameny what does his life an
example tell us about the best way
forward in a world where knowledge is
likely to be more and more recognized as
provisional and hotly contested and
where freedom is always you know a
couple of people at a back room
somewhere away from being extinguished
so 1957 man named Frank Kameny is fired
from his government job as an astronomer
and instead of rolling over he fights
back he goes to Congress he goes to the
Supreme Court he begins mounting public
protests 1971 he's the first openly gay
candidate for Congress now it seems at
first like he never gets anywhere but in
fact at every stage he was making
powerful moral arguments and gathering
more people behind them and the
wonderful thing about a regime of open
criticism and debate is once it gets
going it is very good at finding that
one guy with the important idea the
Galileo the Copernicus the king the
Kemeny bringing that person to the
center testing those ideas and
discovering if they're true that they
really are better ideas Frank Kameny
pioneering activists live to see his
ideas spectacularly vindicated and to
receive a public apology for his firing
from the US government and he never
called for the restriction or
suppression of speech with which he
disagreed
I knew Frank he was a very
confrontational guy but he never said
anyone else should be silenced he always
understood that his job was when people
said stupid or hateful things to use
that as a platform to rebut them and he
understood that he would win those
arguments if he had to be a better ideas
and he did well we'll leave it there
that's a great lesson from a great book
with a great new after
word as well as a great introduction by
George well so thank you Jonathan Roush
thank you